So, ich bin auf jeden Fall on fire, richtig bock jetzt. Gut, wir starten. Ah nee, sollt ihr noch Licht anmachen, das wäre noch eine Idee, gell? Guck mal, auf einmal bin ich hell. So, wir blicken auf die Serie A, die Premier League und La Liga. Es ist mal wieder Zeit für die Ligatour Europa mit Uli Hebel, Christian Bernhardt und Fabian Pakulat. Und genau jetzt geht es los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr, meine Runde hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Servus Jungs.
Mein Lieber, ja, ich sehe schon. Also da haben wir jetzt ein, da haben wir was in dir ausgelöst. Ich bin froh, dass ich diese Abzweigung mit Nottingham gleich genommen habe. Hat mir zwei große Themen ausgelöst.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Nee, ist ja wirklich hochinteressant und ja. Also da werden wir auf jeden Fall nochmal drüber sprechen, wie es dann, wie es da weiterging bei den Spurs. Aber wenn wir beim Abstiegskampf sind, dann können wir ja auch mal wieder nach Italien blicken und über Krimineze sprechen. Christian, die hattest du uns ganz am Anfang der Saison mal mitgebracht. Da lag der Aufsteiger zwischendurch auf Rang 3. Klar, das war nach drei Spieltagen. Also wir haben es auch damals ja schon entsprechend eingeordnet. Aber du hast uns damals ein bisschen erklärt, wie es zu dieser Überraschung kommen konnte. Jetzt ist es noch nicht so, dass man jetzt hier von einem sicheren Abstieg sprechen müsste. Aber es ist aktuell eben Rang 18 mit 3 Punkten Rückstand aktuell auf Letsche. Ist das so das normale? Es hat sich alles wieder so ein bisschen eingependelt auf dem normalen Niveau, in Anführungszeichen bei Cremonese. Die Anfangseuphorie ist verflogen. Oder woran liegt das, dass es eben jetzt diesen ja dann doch Absturz in der Tabelle gab?
Ja, Max, dann probieren wir jetzt mal die Kurve zu kriegen von Tottenham zu Cremonese. Schauen, ob uns das gelingt. Ein Satz noch zu Vicario, nur zu Tottenham. Also da deutet sehr vieles darauf hin, dass der im Sommer nach Italien zurückkehrt. Inter ist da wohl sehr weit in Gesprächen. Juve ist auch interessiert, die brauchen auch eine 1. Also vielleicht tut es ihm auch dann ganz gut, wieder dahin zurückzukommen, wo er ja auch seinen sportlichen Aufstieg, sage ich mal, gestartet hat. Genau. Ja, Cremonese. Nein, es ist schon, Max, ein bisschen mehr als nur dieses Klassische. Das hat sich jetzt vielleicht einsortiert, denn Anfang Dezember war Cremonese noch auf Rang 9. Ich habe mir extra noch mal die Tabelle angeschaut. Sie hatten nur drei Punkte weniger als Juve, nur um das mal ein bisschen einzuordnen, und hatten zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Abstiegsrang. Also die hatten wirklich auch nicht nur dieser Traumstart, sondern es hat schon länger angedauert, dass die einfach über ihre Verhältnisse gespielt haben. Und jetzt aber haben wir das Problem, seit Anfang Dezember haben die 15 Spiele in Folge nicht mehr gewonnen. Also wirklich eine unfassbar lange Serie. Und jetzt sind sie nicht nur da hinten reingerutscht, sondern es schaut im Moment wirklich so aus, als ob sie die schlechtesten Karten hätten. Sie haben jetzt zuletzt gegen die Fiorentina und gegen Lecce, also direkte Konkurrenten, verloren. Sie sind jetzt eben auf dem Abstiegsplatz, haben drei Punkte Rückstand. Und es ist schon komplett jetzt den Bach runtergegangen, muss man sagen. Es kam jetzt auch zum Trainerwechsel unter der Woche. David Nicola, also der Mann, der sie in die Saison geführt hat, ist jetzt entlassen worden. Marc Giampaolo hat übernommen, der auch schon viele Erfahrungen in der Serie hat, gerade mit kleineren Vereinen. War auch schon mal bei Lecce vor, glaube ich, neun oder zehn Jahren in der Serie C, also kennt den Verein. Das interessante an dem Trainerwechsel ist, eigentlich ist David Nicola, hat sich in den letzten Jahren als Feuerwehrmann, als Spezialist entpuppt, der oft eben Mannschaften im Abstiegskampf während der Saison übernommen hat und dann drin gehalten hat und dieses Jahr hat er von Anfang an die Chance bekommen, hat das eben, wie gesagt, monatelang richtig gut gemacht, aber jetzt ist einfach seit Anfang Dezember, kommen die nicht mehr aus dem Loch raus. Ein Sinn bildlich vielleicht, der Name, glaube ich, den die meisten internationalen Zuhörer oder Zuhörerinnen mit Cremonaise verbinden können, ist eben Jamie Vardy, der ja im Sommer nach Cremona gewechselt ist, logisch eine große Nummer. Der hat jetzt auch seit Anfang Dezember nur noch einmal getroffen. Und die Tore von ihm, die er davor auch immer wieder mal geliefert hat, waren halt auch ein Mitgrund, dass sie eben so gut unterwegs waren. Ja, und jetzt bist du halt wirklich so ein Negativstrudel drin. Hast jetzt eben den Trainer gewechselt und musst jetzt wirklich schauen, dass du da irgendwie noch mal die Kurve kriegst. Wie gesagt, sehr schwierig. Also sie haben die direkten Duellen jetzt gegen die Fiorentina. Haben sie zweimal verloren. Gegen Lecce haben sie jetzt verloren. Lecce wirkt sehr gefestigt im Moment. Das ist ähnlich wie die Konstellation wie bei Uli in der Premier League. Also mit Pisa und Hellas sind eigentlich zwei Teams so gut wie weg. Die haben jetzt zwar zuletzt jeweils gewonnen, aber der Rückstand ist eigentlich zu groß. Eigentlich geht es noch um diesen letzten Abstiegsplatz. Und da ist eben die Fiorentina, hat jetzt hin und wieder diese direkten Duellen gewonnen und haben ja schon gesprochen über die Fiorentina. Die hat halt einfach eine andere Qualität, logisch, zur Verfügung. Let's Shame, wie gesagt, hat sich da richtig reingegroovt. Die sind voll in diesem Modus drin. Und im Moment deutet wirklich sehr, sehr viel darauf hin, dass das Gremonese erwischt, obwohl sie diesen überragenden Run von August bis Dezember hatten.
Ja, wie es dann manchmal so geht. Aber ist dann der Kader letztlich dann nicht stabil genug zusammengestellt? Also, was man gesehen hat, aber das ist jetzt leider auch nicht so sehr ja und typisch. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob das was Besonderes ist. Aber irre viele Transferbewegungen in diesem Sommer.
Ja, aber eigentlich war das auch eine Stärke, hat man auch schon angedeutet. Die haben relativ viele erfahrene Spieler geholt, also Abstiegskampfs erfahrene Spieler. Der eine Name, der dafür steht, Federico Basquerotto, den haben sie von Lecce geholt. Der war bei Lecce mit der wichtigste Innenverteidiger. Dann holen sie ihn sozusagen als Aufsteiger. Schwächen damit auch einen direkten Konkurrenten. Also das war schon so ein Signal, oh, okay, Cremonese hat irgendwie erkannt, dass du da auch Leute brauchst, die das kennen. Cremonese war ja sehr lange nicht mehr in der Serie A. Dementsprechend haben sie das eigentlich ganz gut gemacht, haben jetzt im Winter zum Beispiel auch nachgelegt. Sebastiano Luperto, das ist ein sehr erfahrender Innenverteidiger, der kam von Caliere, der spielt halt auch seit Jahren gegen den Abstieg und eigentlich sehr verlässlich. Also eigentlich hat auch da einiges darauf hingedeutet, dass sie das schon gut machen. Also dass das sozusagen das Potenzial schon da ist. Auch da eben im Gegensatz zu anderen kleineren Vereinen im unteren Tabellendrittel, die im Winter gar nicht so viel machen konnten. Also so ein Luperto-Transfer ist schon was, wo du sagst, okay, Aufsteiger holt da nochmal Erfahrungen mit rein. Aber wie gesagt, du bist halt oft, das kennen wir ja glaube ich auch, aus vielen Saisons, aus vielen Ligen. Wenn du mal im Zone negativ strudel drin bist, dann ist das halt auch wahnsinnig schwierig rauszukommen. Sie tun sich offensiv einfach schwer. Also da kommt halt relativ wenig. Wie gesagt, wenn Vardy nicht knipst, Bonazzoli, der hat teilweise am Anfang da Sensationstore geschossen, auch gegen Milan in San Siro zum Sieg. Aber der steht halt auch bei 6 Tore. Also du hast Bonazzoli 6 Tore, Vardy 5 Tore. Und wenn die nicht treffen, dann kommt auch relativ wenig sonst Offensive aus dem Mittelfeld nach. Und dann hast du diesen Negativ-Run. Dann hast du die Fragezeichen im Kopf. Und ja, das ist jetzt im Moment die Gemengelage, die Cremonese wirklich in eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr prekäre Lage jetzt bringt. Ganz klar. Also ich, ich hatte sogar im Gefühl schon vor ein paar Wochen, wenn es blöd für die läuft, dann rutschen die rein. Das Rein-Rutschen ist jetzt mehr als passiert. Und im Moment schaut es sogar danach aus, als ob sie wirklich die schlechtesten Karten auch haben. Also was vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Hoffnung macht, sie haben noch ein paar direkte Duelles. Sie haben jetzt Parma am Wochenende. Das ist logisch ein wahnsinnig wichtiges Spiel. Sie haben Kaliarin noch. Sie haben Pisa noch. Also sie haben schon noch ein paar Spiele, wo sie dann auch sozusagen gegen diese Direkten was machen können. Aber du musst halt irgendwann wieder ein Spiel gewinnen. Nochmal 15 Spiele in Folge ohne Sieg. Ja, da wird es halt irgendwann schwer. Trotz schönem Polster.
Ich meine, immerhin haben sie einen Trainer, Gianpaolo, der es eben auch kennt von Lettche noch und so weiter. Du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Und einmal nur mal ganz kurz, um das zu verdeutlichen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Transferbewegungen. Nur wie viele Spieler sind gekommen und gegangen auf dem Papier. Bei Gremonese 100. 148 sind auf dem Papier gekommen und 52 sind auf dem Papier gegangen. Das sind halt wahnsinnig viele Lien. Deswegen darf man da nicht davon ausgehen, dass die jetzt auch alle da im Locker-Room einen Schrank hatten und so weiter. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die in der Halle sich alle umziehen. Aber das macht es halt eben auch so schwierig, ganz viele Dinge zu bewerten. Weil von außen kannst du überhaupt nicht mehr sagen, ist das jetzt eins von diesen typischen, für die, für die italienische Liga, einfach typischen Laigeschäfte oder ist das jetzt wirklich ein Spieler, der nochmal wichtig wird? Aber deswegen wollte ich das nur nochmal kurz ansprechen. Dann lass mal noch gleich, wir haben ja gerade bei Uli auch einen längeren Stint gemacht. Dann machen wir das einfach in Italien jetzt auch. Wollen wir nochmal an die Tabellen spitze blicken, vielleicht auf Rang 3? Du hast mir mitgegeben, dass sich bei Napoli wieder ein bisschen was getan hat.
Ja, müssen wir vielleicht ansprechen. Das passt auch vielleicht so ein bisschen als übergeordnetes Thema. Also wir hatten Napoli in der Saison, konnte auch stark hinter Kritik, weil Napoli, also A, diese katastrophale Champions League-Saison, da müssen wir ja gar nicht drumherum reden, also als italienischer Meister, sich nicht für die Top 24 zu qualifizieren in der Gruppenphase. Das ist logisch eine absolute Katastrophe. Und in der Liga waren sie eigentlich seit Wochen ja schon raus aus den Meisterrennen. Aber, und deswegen wollte ich es halt ansprechen, das, was für Tottenheim gilt mit den Verletzungs-Sorgen, gilt halt für Napoli auch in dieser Saison. Und ja, da können wir uns ganz kurz überreden. Da muss man dann sicherlich auch über Trainingsplanung, übers Trainerteam auch reden. Da wurden wahrscheinlich gewisse Sachen nicht richtig angegangen. Aber Fakt ist, dass Napoli jetzt monatelang 5 ohne Kevin de Bruyne gespielt hat. Sie haben 4 Monate ohne Franck Anguissage gespielt. Romelu Lukaku hat seine ersten Einsatzminuten Ende Januar gehabt. Also der hat von August bis Januar 0 Minuten für seinen Club spielen können. David Neresch, der Napoli im November, Dezember offensiv getragen hat, ist jetzt mittlerweile seit zweieinhalb Monaten raus. Was ich damit sagen will, sie hatten schon nicht nur viele Verletzungsprobleme, sondern auch wirklich die Crème de la Crème. Ah, Scott Mcdominay sollte ich vielleicht noch nennen. Der war jetzt, glaube ich, eineinhalb oder zwei Monate raus. Was ich damit sagen will, ist, wenn man, man kann viel über Trainer sprechen, man kann viel über Ansätze von Clubs sprechen, über Taktik, was man richtig falsch machen kann. Aber es ist halt ein Unterschied, ob ich Fußball spielen kann mit Scott Mcdominay, Kevin de Bruyne, David Neresch und Frank Anguizá. Oder ob ich das halt monatelang ohne die machen muss. Und deswegen, um hier die Klammer zu schließen, Napoli, jetzt kommen die wieder zurück. Am vergangenen Wochenende lagen sie gegen Lecce zur Halbzeit, 1-0 zurück. In der Halbzeit kommen Kevin de Bruyne und Scott Mcdominay. Mcdominay hat sogar sein Comeback-Hem jetzt nach wochenlanger Pause gefeiert. De Bruyne hatte davor schon mal ein, zwei Kurzeinsätze. Ja, und dann wird es ein komplett anderes Spiel in der zweiten Hälfte. Die zwei haben das an sich gezogen. Napoli hat es noch gewonnen, hat jetzt drei in Folge gewonnen, ist nur noch ein Punkt hinter Milan sozusagen. Und deswegen wollte ich das Thema kurz bringen, dass es logisch schon einen großen Unterschied ausmacht, mit welcher Qualität ich halt meine Ideen sozusagen auf dem Feld umsetzen kann. Und ich sage mal so, das hilft uns jetzt nicht mehr weiter in Sachen Meisterkampf in Italien. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, wenn Napoli drei oder vier Punkte mehr hätte, dann würden die Inter noch ein paar zumindest mentale Probleme bereiten. Weil Inter ist jetzt wirklich so ein bisschen übers Spielmodus, hat ein paar Fragezeichen. Napoli ist jetzt einfach zu weit weg. Neun Punkte, das wird nichts mehr. Neun Spieltage vor Schluss. Aber ich habe das Leistegefühl, wenn Napoli auf sechs dran wäre. Napoli traue ich jetzt wirklich zu, dass die auch die nächsten drei, vier, fünf Spiele noch gewinnen. Weil wirklich alle Großen zurückkommen. Weil alle Großen, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, haben ja ein großes Ziel im Sommer. Nämlich die wollen bei der WM auch eine Rolle spielen. Also auch die intrinsische Motivation, glaube ich, vieler Spieler wie von McTominay, wie von de Bruyne und so. Da geht es ja auch darum, was im Juni dann für die passiert. Dementsprechend haben da viele wirklich ein großes Interesse, jetzt auch in diesen letzten Saisonmonaten nochmal richtig in Schwung zu kommen. Und deswegen, schade aus Napolis Sicht, ich glaube echt, mit ein paar Punkten näher, hätten sie vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen, zumindest Druck auf Inter machen können. So logischerweise waren die letzten Monate einfach. Waren sie zu früh oder letzten Wochen, sie waren zu früh, zu weit weg. Und das Thema ist jetzt durch. Aber sie werden total easy und locker in die Champions League kommen.
Ja, und das muss aus Sicht von Lecce auch wirklich schwierig sein. Du führst ab der dritten Minute 1 zu 0. Wir haben ja gerade Lecce indirekt auch mit besprochen. Was hätte das bedeutet? Dann wäre die Situation für Kriminese noch schlechter. Ja, und dann wechseln die halt einfach in der Pause McTominay und de Bruyne ein und machen ja auch direkt dann den Ausgleich.
Und das war wirklich so ein Spiel, nicht nur, weil sie es drehen und sie gewinnen sie auch nur 2-1. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt Lecce weggeschossen hätten. Aber du hast gemerkt, vor allen Dingen in de Bruyne, man merkt echt, es war ja auch ganz ruhig um ihn geworden. Er hat sich ja lange in Belgien auch behandeln lassen. Also er hatte ja diese schwere Muskelverletzung, war dann auch wochenlang gar nicht in Neapel. Da gab es dann auch immer mal so ein paar Fragen. Wann kommt der wieder? Wie schaut denn das aus? Und dann ist es relativ ruhig. Plötzlich hieß es im Februar, de Bruyne ist wieder in Neapel. Und dann kam er jetzt auch bald wieder in den Rhythmus. Und du hast jetzt gesehen, wie gesagt, es ist halt was anderes, wenn de Bruyne die Passfenster, die dir in de Bruyne öffnet, die Passlinien, ist halt was anderes. Dann kommt dieser Mcdominy dazu, der ja Napoli eh schon seit eineinhalb Jahren trägt. Also im Prinzip ist es schon, man kann Fußball wahnsinnig viel besprechen. Aber viel macht dann halt schon die Spielerqualität aus. Und das sieht man jetzt halt bei Napoli wirklich geballt, weil eben so viele so wichtige Spieler jetzt plötzlich gleichzeitig zurückkommen. Angizaya auch. Angizay ist für das Spiel dieser Napolimannschaft ja schon seit Skudetto-Zeiten, seit Spalletti enorm wichtig. Der war halt auch drei bis vier Monate raus. Und ja, jetzt hast du die halt wieder. Ja, dann schaut der Schnack schon anders aus.
Dann schaut der Schnack anders aus. Also, bei Napoli werden jetzt auch wieder die kleinsten Passfenster getroffen. Wenn du magst, dann schließt sich jetzt dein Podcastfenster. Christian, du hast noch andere Dinge zu tun. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du dir trotzdem Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, danke euch. Sorry, dass ich früher weg muss und viel Spaß noch.
Entspann dich, ne? Bis bald.
Gut, also, ciao, ciao.
Und wir blicken nochmal nach Spanien. Mensch, Fabian, jetzt musstest du eine ganze Weile hier warten. Aber ich habe eine Anekdote, mit der ich dein neues Thema einleiten kann. Wusstest du eigentlich, dass ich mal Martin de Mekeles fast zum FC Bayern gebracht hätte? Ich werde es nicht in allen Details jetzt auserzählen können hier, aber es begab sich zu der Zeit, als der FC Bayern mal wieder einen Trainer suchte. Ich glaube, es war nach Nagelsmann. Ach, als Trainer.
Ich dachte, als Spieler.
Nein, nein, nein, als Trainer. Dann saß ich in der Arena und habe mit einem Kollegen– Namen werden hier nicht genannt– gesagt, jetzt sind sie so verzweifelt, bald werden sie de Mekeles holen, einfach nur weil er gerade Erfolg in Südamerika hat, auch wenn keiner weiß, wie er spielen lässt. Ich kenne inzwischen auch, wie sich die Flüsterpost weiterentwickelt hat. Am Ende der Flüsterpost stand auf jeden Fall eine Sky90-Sendung, in der ein anwesender Journalist gesagt hat, wie wäre es denn mit Martin de Mekeles und Lothar Matthäus dann darauf reagieren musste. Du hast gesehen, er hat, wie wir alle, nichts von Martin de Mekeles Fußball gesehen. Er hat dann nur Dinge gesagt wie, er ist natürlich ein etablierter Spieler, er kennt den FC Bayern gut, spielt seinen eigenen Fußball, könnte eine Option sein. Dann war Martin de Mekeles auf einmal mal für 2-3 Tage ein Thema, bis dann E-Ball, glaube ich, gesagt hat. Ja, Leute, der ist es nicht. Aber jetzt endlich hat es Martin de Mekeles geschafft, er ist im europäischen Fußball gelandet, und zwar in Spanien.
In Spanien, genau, bei Real Mallorca ist er gelandet. Er war ja, habe ich ja völlig falsch geschrieben dir, er war ja schon in Europa, er hatte schon bei Bayern die zweite Mannschaft trainiert und die U19. Also es ist jetzt seine erste Profi-Station, muss man ja so sagen. Und ganz kurz vielleicht noch zu deiner Anekdote, als er beim FC Malaga damals gespielt hat, in unserer wahnsinnigen Scheichphase, hatte ich die Chance, mit ihm auch privat ein Interview zu führen, ein längeres, und konnte ihn dann ein bisschen über Fußball ausfragen und war sehr, sehr positiv überrascht, was er alles zu berichten hatte. Hat ihn auch nicht so wissens, ja wie soll ich sagen, nicht so eingeschätzt. Also hat mich da wirklich fasziniert, was er über Fußball erzählt hat, was er über die Spielweise erzählt hat, was er über Bayern erzählt hat, was er über Malaga erzählt hat, wie sie spielen, was er so erlebt hat. Und man hat schon rausgehört, dass der deutlich mehr kann, als nur den Innenverteidiger Gautschütter die Bälle wegschlägt, sondern Martin Demetelis. Würd ich auf der Liste weiter beobachten. Ich glaube, das kann schon noch eine interessante Trainerfigur werden. Und jetzt hat es ja geklappt mit seiner ersten Traineranstellung in Spanien. Da ist er ja auch sehr gerne und hat diesen Job jetzt bei Real Mallorca angenommen, der gar nicht so leicht ist. Denn er hat die, er muss Mallorca vor dem Abstieg retten und hat eigentlich nur einen Vertrag bis Ende der Saison. Das heißt, es ist auch so, wenn er es nicht schafft, dann hat er sich vielleicht auch schon viel verbaut wieder hier. Dementsprechend geht er auch ein bisschen ins Risiko. Er hat aber ganz ordentlich begonnen, hat in seinen ersten zwei Spielen vier Punkte geholt. Das erste Spiel hätte er eigentlich gewinnen müssen. Da waren sie 0-2 vorne bei Osasuna, haben dann in den letzten Minuten des Spiels, 89. und 94., noch zwei Tore bekommen, sodass es 2 zu 2 ausging. War aber, wie gesagt, dort schon sehr nahe am ersten Sieg. Das hat jetzt am letzten Wochenende geklappt. Es war gegen Espanol Barcelona mit 2 zu 1. Espanol ist oben mit dabei, es war also kein einfacher Gegner. Man muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, Espanol hat in diesem Spiel wahrscheinlich mehr verdient. Sie haben ein sehr strittiges 1 zu 1 bekommen. Espanol war 0-1 vorne. Das 1 zu 1 von Mallorca, wahrscheinlich ein Foulspiel vorangegangen, das der Schiri nicht geahndet hat, der auch nicht zum Waag rufen wurde, um sich das anzuschauen. Spanien-Schiedsrichter-Wesen ist nach wie vor Katastrophe. Liga sind wahnsinnig schlecht.
Es kann nicht sein, deutsche Schiedsrichter sind die Schlechtesten. Das kann ich sein, Fabian.
Also, deutsche Schiedsrichter würde ich mit Kuss an dir nehmen. Also wirklich. Und sogar die aus der 2. Liga. Also wirklich Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, was hier passiert. In Spanien gibt es ja nach wie vor die Regel, wenn du als Schiedsrichter zweimal vom Waag rausgerufen wirst, bist du erstmal für ein Spiel gesperrt. Das heißt, die Schiedsrichter wollen sich auch gar nicht vom Waag beeinflussen lassen und bestehen dann auf ihre teilweise eben auch Fehlentscheidungen. Und in dem Fall war es eins. Für Martin Dimitjelis war es super, denn es war der Ausgleich. Und Mallorca hat dann das Spiel auch in der Schlussphase noch gedreht, mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen und hat sich jetzt ein klein bisschen Luft verschafft. Im Abstiegskampf ist, glaube ich, jetzt zwei Punkte vor den Abstiegszonen. Ist nach wie vor natürlich alles brandgefährlich. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es eine sehr, sehr interessante Personalie. Ich wünsche ihm persönlich sehr, sehr viel Glück. Im Moment geht es um Abstiegskampf. Das heißt, spielerisch, was können wir groß berichten? Er hat die Mannschaft mehr zusammengeführt. Das Zentrum wird dichtgemacht. Es sind vier Mittelfeldspieler da. Er setzt auf eine Zehn, die im Moment Pablo Torre macht. Der ist vom FC Barcelona ausgelehnt. Er hat noch einen anderen Zehner, Sergi Dader. Der ist im Moment meistens von der Bank. Der ist auch beim FC Malaga groß geworden, war mal kurz vorm Nationalspieler. Er hat vorne mit Werdat Muriki aus Albanien einen tollen Stürmer, der nach wie vor für die wichtigen Tore sorgt. Aber es ist im Moment alles darauf ausgerichtet, erst mal hinten dicht zu stehen, aus dem Zentrum dann nach vorne zu spielen. Im Moment hat er jetzt, wie gesagt, vier Punkte geholt. Mallorca ist wieder ganz gut auf ihn zu sprechen. Es wird schon diskutiert, ob er einen Vertrag jetzt schon bekommen soll. Aber gut, es wird noch ein bisschen dauern. Mallorca, vielleicht noch ganz interessant, ist im Besitz dreier Amerikaner und zwar dreier amerikanischen Ex-Sportler. Andy Kohlberg ist Eigentümer und Präsident. Das war mal ein Tennisspieler. Steve Nash und Steve Kerr kennen wir vielleicht noch, die Namen aus der NBA. Und das sind die Eigentümer von Mallorca. Die haben auch vor ein paar Jahren Neustarling gebaut und haben auf jeden Fall eher die Absichten, nach oben zu gehen. Und hatten das in den letzten Jahren auch immer stückweise so ein bisschen geschafft, in der Liga sich nach oben zu arbeiten. Dieses Jahr hat es aber nicht so gut ausgesehen. Und jetzt muss eben Demicelis Mallorca erstmal retten und dann nächstes Jahr vielleicht was aufbauen.
Das wäre wirklich was. Und also aus dem Persönlichen höre ich nur die besten Geschichten. Jetzt von dir über Martin Demicelis. Ole Zeissler hat auch, als er mal seinen Derby-Film gemacht hat, auch nur in höchsten Tönen von ihm gesprochen und noch so über zwei, drei andere Ecken auch sehr, sehr schöne, sehr, sehr gute Geschichten. Also es scheint jemand zu sein, der sehr zugänglich ist.
Ich würde es ihm auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass es jetzt erst mal klappt mit dem Nichtabstieg, weil wie gesagt, wenn er jetzt das nicht schaffen sollte, dann wird es natürlich in Europa schwer. Wenn er es schafft, dann hat er sich eine Bühne aufbereitet. Und wie gesagt, in Spanien hat er einen guten Namen, in Deutschland glaube ich auch. Wird ein interessanter Trainer, ist 45 Jahre, da werden wir noch ein bisschen was von hören. Hoffentlich.
Ich möchte diese Folge hier mit Big Easy Muck widmen. If you know, you know. Dann lass uns noch dein zweites kurzes Thema annehmen. Wir haben mitbekommen oder vielleicht haben sie höheren oder höheren mitbekommen, Barca hat einen neuen alten Präsidenten und der ist ja auch Riesenfan von Hansi Flick. Und das ist für Hansi Flick, der ja auch sehr erfolgreich gerade ist, sicherlich nichts schlechtes.
Genau. Er soll auch seinen Vertrag verlängern. Er hat, glaube ich, bis 2027 Vertrag. Der soll noch mal ein Jahr herausgezogen, würde ich schon sagen, also verlängert werden. Er macht einen guten Job bei Barcelona nach wie vor, Hansi Flick. Er fühlt sich dort pudelwohl. Er hat auch gesagt, das möchte er. Es soll seine letzte Trainerstation sein. Und Laporta, du hast es gerade angesprochen, der Präsident hat vor ein paar Tagen die Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen, hat diese gefeiert wie ein Rapstar. Weiß ich nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken soll. War wirklich unfassbar, was dafür zu sehen ist. Also dann noch um 3 Uhr in einem Club mit allen zusammen. Und die Spieler sind zur Wahl gekommen. Die hat er dann extra hingeführt und geshakert. Und er ist absolut da.
Der Außermarkt André Tastegen, der durfte nicht wählen.
Der durfte nicht wählen, ihr habt es mitbekommen in Deutschland, okay. Bei Laporta ist es dann immer so, Leute, die irgendwie vielleicht was gegen ihn haben könnten, die dürfen dann verschiedene Sachen machen.
Ja, Moment mal, also man muss das kurz erklären. Also jeder, der spielt bei Barca, der wird automatisch Barca-Mitglied. Und nur Barca-Mitglieder dürfen logischerweise den Präsidenten wählen. Und Marc-André Tastegen ist sogar zur Wahl erschienen. Aber es hieß, dass er in der Mitgliederliste nicht mehr verzeichnet ist. Oder wie ist das so richtig wiedergegeben?
Ja, so ungefähr. Also ganz genau habe ich dann auch nicht mehr verfolgt. Aber ich habe ihn nur gesehen, wie er da an dieser Wahlurne stand und eigentlich schon wählen wollte. Und sein Name taucht auf keiner Liste auf.
Er wird einfach bis zuletzt unwürdig behandelt. Der arme Marc-André, ey, das ist wirklich… Kommt zurück zu Gladbach, da wissen Sie das nicht.
Es ist nicht seine Saison, es ist nicht seine Saison, kann man leider so sagen.
Das wird jetzt passieren, das ist klar, wie bei David Chiles damals.
Ja, das stimmt, genau.
Gladbach bei Sky 90 am Sonntag.
Ich habe es zu öffentlich gesagt. Niemand würde sich öffentlich auf den Rasenfunk beziehen wollen. Aber die sehr direkte Flüsterpost, die damals in Gang gesetzt wurde, einfach nur von einem… Die war schon lustig. Aber gut, das kann ich euch auf einmal nochmal erzählen, wie das genau lief dann.
Naja, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so, La Porta ist nach wie vor im Amt. Das neue Stadion ist jetzt wirklich voll einsatzfähig und Barca läuft es gut. Mit Hansi Flick, wie gesagt, hat er alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, damals La Porta. Das war ja kein unumstrittener Transfer. Er hätte auch schön in die andere Richtung gehen können. Aber es passt im Moment einfach zwischen Flick, Barca und den Spielern natürlich. Und auch in der Liga und in der Champions League sind sie gut dabei. Haben auch ganz keinen, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, eine super saubere Saison hinter sich. Viele Verletzungs-Sorgen auch gehabt. La Minia mal immer wieder mit Leistenproblemen. Rafinha hatte mal ein kleines Loch, Lewandowski war mal verletzt. Aber sie kompensieren das gut. Sie haben natürlich aus der eigenen Jugend nach wie vor einen unsagbar großen Fundus an Nachwuchsspielern, die dann kommen können, wenn es irgendwie brennt. Und Flick managt das gut und fühlt sich, wie gesagt, wohl in Barcelona und wird wahrscheinlich jetzt die nächsten Tage bis 28 nochmal verlängern. Und schauen wir mal, was Barcelona dann dieses Jahr noch an Titeln erreicht. Einen haben sie ja nicht mehr oder können sie nicht mehr reichen. Das ist der Copa del Rey, das sind sehr geben. Atletico Madrid ausgeschieden und das ist ja auch jetzt das kommende Champions League Duell, wird also nicht ganz unspannend. Ich glaube vor allen Dingen Basa tut sich dann gegen solche Teams wie Atletico deutlich schwerer als vielleicht irgendwelche internationalen Teams. Deswegen glaube ich, wird das doch deutlich enger, als man es vielleicht im Moment vermutet.
Ja, das war ja das mit dem Hinspiel 4 zu 0 bei Atletico und dann im Rückspiel 3 zu 0 für Basa. Ob ihm das noch mal passiert, so ein Hinspiel, wobei diesmal ist die Konstellation ja eine andere, also anders herum. Ah ja, da kann man wirklich sehr gespannt drauf sein. Mensch, ihr jetzt nur noch zwei. Das hat mal wieder Spaß gemacht, mit euch über den europäischen Fußball zu sprechen. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Danke dir, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast.
Sehr gerne. Hat mir Spaß gemacht, wie immer.
Sollte es irgendjemanden noch nicht mitbekommen haben, es gibt ein Tribüngespräch zu eurem Buch, das erschienen ist. Hoffentlich haben die TV im Himmel, ist natürlich in den Show Notes verlinkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Definitiv kann man sich bestellen, am besten in der örtlichen Buchhandlung. Vielleicht nicht bei dem großen Versand, der einem als ersten einfällt. Aus Gründen, aus vielerlei Gründen, muss man sagen. Also danke dir, lieber Uli, und danke, lieber Fabian. Du musst noch ein Buch schreiben, damit ich das hier in die Kamera halten kann. Aber ich würde das definitiv lesen.
Es wird ein Buch über den FC Malaga. Du wirst das irgendwann noch mitbekommen. Es ist unwahrscheinlich spannend, was hier passiert. Vielleicht steigen wir dieses Jahr tatsächlich wieder in die 1. Liga auf. Und dann wird es nächstes Jahr im Rasenfunk aber richtig rund gehen.
Und wenn dann der Titel nicht der Malaga-Bächer ist, dann verstehe ich die Welt nicht mehr.
Ja, das kriegen wir hin. Also danke dir, lieber Fabian. Und in Abwesenheit natürlich auch nochmal danke an Christian Bernhard. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, das erfahrt ihr, wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dann auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. Außerdem ist auch eine Video unter der Podcast-Beschreibung alles nochmal verlinkt. Geht via PayPal oder andere Wege ja inzwischen sehr, sehr schnell. Wir haben auch so einen QR-Code, den man einfach nur abscannen muss auf der Webseite. Dann könntet ihr einen Dauerauftrag einrichten, wenn ihr das möchtet. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei CK3, bei Sigofa, bei Julia, bei Dimitri und bei Andreas K. Sie alle haben uns in der Vergangenheit unterstützt. Vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Feedback zu dieser Folge sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr dem Rasenfunk gewogen bleibt. Und abonniert auch sehr gerne mal das Tribügengespräch, denn zum einen gibt es da die Sendung eben mit den beiden Hebes. Und da wird es auch was geben, was ich heute schon mal so ein bisschen so indirekt angeteased habe. Kommt dann nächste Woche. Bleibt oder werdet gesund. Macht's gut. Ciao!